Another major difference
between Android security and
iOS security is code signing.
Android takes a very
different approach from iOS.
In particular,
all apps are self-signed by developers.
A developer can create his own
power key, self sign it to create
a certificate for its public key and
then use that key to sign his apps.
In other words, third party Android apps
are not signed by a central authority.
There's no vetting process for
third party app developers.
This means that anybody can
become an Android app developer,
self-sign its apps and
upload it to Android Play Store.
So, if code signing is not used to make
sure that apps are from the vetted or
verified developer, what is it used for?
Code signing is used for
making sure updates for
an app are coming from
the same developer.
In addition,
code signing is used to manage
the trust relationship between apps,
so that they can share code and data.